all right let's talk a little bit about
climate because it's become fairly clear
to anyone paying attention that as
we shift out of kovid mania the system
the machine is going to need more
craziness to further lock down further
control us further figure out ways to
manipulate us further figure out ways to
keep us scared and angry and everything
else and i do sense and i really do that
the covet thing is starting to
uh i would say close up like they're not
going to stop with the fear-mongering
and everything else but i think a lot of
people are finally just moving on i
really believe it so they've got to
figure out something else because they
can't have you walking around not in
fear just thinking straight and looking
around and seeing the world around you
and making individual thoughts and
choices for yourself they can't have
that right so they've got to keep the
covet thing going so here's some video
of jen saki she is back after she got
coveted and had to take about 10 days
off she was vaccinated for covet somehow
got covered don't tell joy behar that
would be very upsetting uh and i think
what saki says here kind of lends itself
to the way that they are going to uh
increase the fear take a look just to be
clear i know that's been a criticism so
that's why i said that not an accurate
one look our view is that the rise in
gas prices over the long term makes it
an even stronger case for doubling down
our investment and our focus on clean
energy options so that we are not
relying on uh the fluctuations and opec
and their
willingness to put more supply and meet
the demands in the market
man it's so dangerous what she said
right there if you really listen to what
she's saying she's basically going yeah
gas prices are rising so we're gonna
have to do more of our green stuff our
recycling stuff our renewable stuff now
i'm not against green things i'm not
against uh doing all sorts of things
related to say nuclear power i know that
scares these people even though it's
deeply deeply safe and we now know that
and they're trying to close all these
nuclear power plants um but what she's
saying is as gas prices rise we're gonna
have to do more of all that stuff that
we've been trying to push down your
throats with build back better and our
crazy bills and lunatic aoc and
everything else so wouldn't it behoove
them then to actually
raise gas prices wouldn't if you really
believe that you wanted to transfer
everybody over to green power and the
green new deal and their green
dystopia
although they believe it's a utopia
wouldn't you then do everything you
could to make gas as expensive as
possible wouldn't you do everything you
could to destroy the economy if you're
really saying we have to build back
better we have to completely change
things and by the way this is what
they're saying right they're telling us
that what an opportunity there is after
kovid to really look at how we do
everything in america and fundamentally
change things and you silly silly decent
liberals the last 20 of you that thought
that old joe biden was going to stop it
he has ushered it in more than
absolutely anyone else
so it would actually benefit the people
who want us to get to this green thing
that will never really work and is going
to cause so many problems and cause
actually all sorts of uh depression for
uh poorer people i discussed that with
jordan peterson like the best way to
help poor people is through cheaper
energy resources right but that's not
really what they're interested in check
out my interview with jordan peterson
from last week if you want to get a
little bit more on that but basically
she's telling you the part that she's
not supposed to tell you we're happy
when gas prices go up and perhaps we
would do everything we could to make gas
prices go up and by the way we're kind
of happy when the supply chain gets
screwed up because then that kind of
proves that capitalism doesn't really
work so we'll have to figure out ways to
maybe socialize uh the system right
we'll have to make sure that our
infrastructure system has far more
government involvement and much less uh
capitalist competition that would make
sense that they're telling you what
they're doing and if you don't think
that's enough we we saw this video over
the weekend i saw this one
this is the minister of environment and
climate change of canada you know we've
been going through this big climate
conference these people all fly in their
private jets across the world most of
them like barack obama live in 11
million dollar estates in martha's
vineyard right on the water you'd think
they'd move inland but they don't it's
very weird uh well stephen bildbeau who
is the minister of environment and
climate change in canada uh had uh
something very interesting to say about
climate and i think you'll see the
intersectional nature of this stupidity
mr chair i would like to say that canada
strongly support strong languages
on the rights of indigenous peoples and
the inclusion of their traditional law
knowledge in in the fight against
climate change as well as the protection
of human rights
as part of this text thank you very much
mr speaker
okay i have no problem with indigenous
people right that's just fine if you
your people came from a certain place
and you're still there and you're doing
your thing but do you see by the way
they combine all of these things climate
change has absolutely nothing to do with
indigenous people he talks about the
traditional knowledge of indigenous
people to fight climate change is there
something that an indigenous person by
their birth knows more about climate
change than say the average scientist
who perhaps has been studying it who
maybe didn't come from the place that
they live on now like most of us and
most of our families and most of our
history most of man's history is a
history of people moving all over the
world and all sorts of wars have been
fought and civilizations have uh grown
and civilizations have crumbled like is
there anything is there anything he says
the traditional knowledge of indigenous
people
it's a completely nonsensical statement
but they love it they love it again they
just clap on oh my god indigenous people
we like indigenous people traditional
knowledge we like traditional knowledge
somehow it's against capitalism we like
being against capitalism
these people are so boring anyway i tell
you all of this just to say uh start
watching out for this the next thing
that's coming is the climate stuff there
will be climate lockdowns they will not
want cars on the road they will tell you
to stay in your house and use less heat
when it's cold and use less air
conditioning with it when it's hot and a
whole bunch of other stuff it's just on
the way i'm gonna fight it why not